SHOW.
FIRST, MICHAEL COHEN SPENT A
DECADE AS TRUMP'S HIGH-PROFILE
LOBBYER, AND DEFENDER AND
PERSONAL ATTORNEY.
ONE DAY HE DECIDED HE HATED
DONALD TRUMP AND BECAME HIS
MORTAL ENEMY.
HOW DID THAT HAPPEN?
COHEN TOLD CONGRESS HE WAS
PERSONALLY AND IS MORALLY
OFFENDED BY WHAT HIS BOSS SAID
ON TWO OCCASIONS.
LATER WHEN HE WATCHED TRUMP'S
MEETING WITH VLADIMIR PUTIN.
THAT CHANGED MICHAEL COHEN'S
MIND FOREVER.
DEMOCRATS MUST HAVE BEEN
GRATIFYED TO HEAR THAT.
MICHAEL COHEN IS A SENSITIVE,
PROGRESSIVE NOW.
TORMENTED BY CLIMATE CHANGE.
A ONE MAN CRUSADE AGAINST
PRIVILEGE.
HE IS A NEW MAN.
THAT'S HIS STORY.
NOW COMES THE DAILY MAIL PIECE
THAT PUTS A DIFFERENT GLOSS ON
IT.
JUST WEEKS BEFORE THE FBI RAIDED
HIS OFFICES LAST SUMMER, MICHAEL
COHEN WAS SHOPPING A BOOK
PROPOSAL.
COHEN PROFESSES LOVE AND
ADMIRATION FOR DONALD TRUMP AND
DEFENDS THE PRESIDENT AGAINST
CLAIMS HE IS CRAZY, DUMB, IN
OVER HIS HEAD OR A LIAR, ALL
CLAIMS COHEN MADE THIS WEEK
BEFORE CONGRESS.
MICHAEL COHEN IS NOT A RELIABLE
NARRATOR.
BUT HE IS THE NARRATE
BUT HE IS THE NARRAOR THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE CHOSEN.
THEY BROUGHT HIM TO CAPITOL HILL
TO PROVE THE RUSSIAN CONSPIRACY
TRUE.
HE DIDN'T.
HE DEMOLISHED.
LET'S START WITH THE CLAIM THAT
COHEN HELD SECRET MEETINGS WITH
RUSSIANS IN PRAGUE TO STEAL THE
ELECTION.
ON ITS FACE IT SOUNDS NUTS BUT
THEY HAVE BEEN TELLING YOU THAT.
>> ROBERT MUELLER HAS EVIDENCE
THAT TRUMP'S PERSONAL LAWYER AND
FIXER MICHAEL COHEN MADE A LATE
SUMMER TRIP TO PRAGUE DURING THE
2016 PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
CONFIRMATION OF THE TRIP WAS
CONFIRMED FROM THE STEELE
DOSSIER.
>> I HEAR THERE WERE REPORTS
MR. COHEN WAS IN PRAGUE, THERE
IS MORE AND MORE INDICATIONS
THAT THERE IS SOMETHING HERE
THAT IS FAR, FAR FROM BEING
ANYTHING NEAR A WITCH HUNT.
>> Tucker: THAT WAS JOHN
BRENNAN.
HE WAS THE HEAD OF THE CIA.
AS YOU JUST SAW, HE CLAIMED TO
BELIEVE THAT.
COHEN WENT TO PRAGUE.
IT'S THE PERFECT CONSPIRACY.
BUT MICHAEL COHEN HAS NEVER BEEN
TO PRAGUE AND TESTIFIED ABOUT
THAT YESTERDAY.
>> YOU HAVE EVER BEEN TO PRAGUE?
>> I NEVER BEEN TO PRAGUE OR THE
CZECH REPUBLIC.
>> Tucker: HOW FRUSTRATING IT
MUST HAVE BEEN FOR SCHIFF TO
HEAR THAT.
THIS WAS WHERE COHEN WAS
SUPPOSED TO ADMIT SWIPING
MICRO-FILM WITH VLADIMIR PUTIN.
HOW ABOUT THE CLAIM THAT
VLADIMIR PUTIN'S AGENTS HAVE
VIDEO OF DONALD TRUMP CAVORTING
WITH HOOKERS AND THAT'S HOW THEY
BLACK MAILED TRUMP TO SAY NICE
THINGS ABOUT RUSSIA.
>> THE STEELE DOSSIER SAID
RUSSIA HAS DIRT ON THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES EXPOSING
THE PRESIDENT TO BLACKMAIL.
>> THERE IS A VERY REAL
POSSIBILITY THAT PRESIDENT PUTIN
HOLDS DAMAGING INFORMATION OVER
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> WHAT DO THE RUSSIANS HAVE ON
DONALD TRUMP?
POLITICALLY, PERSONALLY OR
FINANCIALLY?
>> Tucker: OKAY.
IF THERE IS A HOOKER TAPE OUT
THERE, IT'S FAIR TO ASSUME THAT
MICHAEL COHEN WOULD KNOW ABOUT
IT.
HE IS THAT KIND OF GUY.
NOW WOULD BE THE TIME HE WOULD
TELL US ALL ABOUT IT.
BUT NO.
>> ARE YOU AWARE OF ANYTHING THE
PRESIDENT HAS DONE AT HOME OR
ABROAD TO SUBJECT HIM TO
EXTORTION OR BLACKMAIL?
>> NO.
>> ARE YOU AWARE OF ANY
VIDEOTAPES THAT MIGHT BE THE
SUBJECT OF EXTORTION OR
BLACKMAIL?
>> I HAVE HEARD ABOUT THESE
TAPES FOR ALONG TIME.
I HAD MANY PEOPLE CONTACT ME
OVER THE YEARS.
I HAVE NO REASON TO BELIEVE THAT
TAPE EXISTS.
>> Tucker: DAMN, HE DID IT
AGAIN.
INSTEAD OF CONFIRMING THE
RUSSIAN CONSPIRACY THAT
CONTROLLED AMERICAN POLITICS FOR
MORE THAN 2 YEARS, MICHAEL COHEN
REFUTED IT.
THIS IS FRUSTRATING.
WHERE DO WE GET THE PART WHERE
HE BLOWS THE RUSSIA CASE WIDE
OPEN AND THEY LEAD BIG ORANGE
AWAY IN HANDCUFFS AND HILLARY
CLINTON CAN BE THE PRESIDENT.
LET'S ASK HIM DIRECTLY.
IT'S ALMOST A RHETORICAL
QUESTION.
DEMOCRATS ARE CERTAIN IT
HAPPENED.
>> I THINK THERE IS PLENTY OF
EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION IN PLAIN
SIGHT.
>> TRUMP HAS THE KREMLIN KLAN
SURROUNDING HIM.
THERE IS MORE TO BE LEARNED
ABOUT IT.
I BELIEVE THERE HAS BEEN
COLLUSION.
>> IT'S SMELLING MORE AND MORE
LIKE COLLUSION.
>> WE SAW COLD, HARD EVIDENCE OF
THE TRUMP CAMP PAIN AND THE
TRUMP FAMILY INTENDING TO
COLLUDE, POSSIBLY, WITH RUSSIA.
>> Tucker: THESE PEOPLE.
PLENTY OF EVIDENCE.
COLD, HARD EVIDENCE!
IF ANYONE CAN PROVIDE THAT KIND
OF EVIDENCE, IT WOULD BE MICHAEL
COHEN.
HE WAS A PERSONAL ATTORNEY TO A
MAN WHO ACCEPTED RUBLES.
SO WHAT IS THE ANSWER.
>> BASED ON WHAT YOU KNOW, DID
MR. TRUMP LIE ABOUT COLLUDING
AND ACCORDING WITH THE RUSSIAN
AT THIS POINT DURING THE
CAMPAIGN?
>> AS I STATED IN MY TESTIMONY,
I WOULD NOT USE THE WORD
"COLLUDING."
WAS THERE SOMETHING ODD ABOUT
THE BACK AND FORTH PRAISE WITH
THE PRESIDENT PUTIN?
YES.
BUT I AM NOT REALLY SURE THAT I
CAN ANSWER THAT QUESTION IN
TERMS OF COLLUSION.
>> Tucker: THE BALLOON JUST
DEFLATED.
TALK ABOUT A LET DOWN.
NO MEETING IN PRAGUE.
NO RUSSIAN CONSPIRACY IS.
IT WAS A HOAX.
YOU HAVE TO FEEL SILLY RIGHT NOW
IF YOU EVER BELIEVED ANY OF
THIS.
WE HAVE ONE LAST IDEA.
THERE IS STILL A WAY MICHAEL
COHEN COULD SEND DONALD TRUMP TO
PRISON EVEN WITHOUT RUSSIA.
WHAT IF COHEN CONFIRMED THAT
TRUMP TOLD HIM TO LIE TO
CONGRESS.
THAT WOULD BE OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE.
THAT WOULD BE A CRIME.
BUZZ FEED RAN A STORY ALLEGING
THAT HAPPENED.
BUZZ FEED IS RUN BY UNHAPPY
PEOPLE IN BROOKLYN.
MAYBE THERE IS SOMETHING THIS.
CABLE NEWS WAS CONVINCED.
>> IT WOULD BE A BOMBSHELL
INFORMATION.
>> A BOMBSHELL REPORT.
>> IF THIS IS TRUE.
>> Tucker: THE LATEST BOMBSHELL.
OUR LAST OPEN TO END THIS
PRESIDENCY AND RETURN TO THE
STATUS QUO OF 2020.
OUR HOPES ARE ON YOU MICHAEL
COHEN
IT HAPPEN?
THE REVEAL.
>> YOU LIED TO CONGRESSIONAL
COMMITTEES, IS THAT CORRECT?
>> PREVIOUSLY.
>> CORRECT.
>> YES, SIR.
>> YOU STATED THAT TRUMP NEVER
DIRECTED YOU TO LIE TO CONGRESS,
IS THAT CORRECT?
>> THAT'S CORRECT.
>> Tucker: 4 FOR 4.
GAME, SET, MATCH.
THE TRUMP PRESIDENCY CONTINUES.
OTHER TEAM LOOKS DESPONDENT.
YOU COULD HEAR WEEPING FROM THE
PRESS BOX.
WHAT ABOUT ALL OF THE LIES YOU
JUST HEARD, NOT FROM COHEN FROM
THE OTHERS.
BLACKMAIL AND COLLUSION AND
RUSSIA, RUSSIA, RUSSIA!
ARE ANY OF THE LIARS GOING TO BE
PUNISHED FOR LYING?
WILL ANYBODY LOSE A JOB OR
REPUTATION?
MAYBE WHAT HAPPENED TO CARTER
PAGE?
ANY PENALTY FOR BEING DISHONEST
FOR 2 SOLID YEARS AND MISLEADING
THE PUBLIC IN THE SERVICE OF A
POLITICAL AGENDA, THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY?
IS A SINGLE PERSON GOING TO